let's talk about the latest developments
regarding the draft which begins in only
15
days there have been multiple reports
from nfl media which is owned and
operated by the nfl so we assume that
this information is being leaked to the
reporters is accurate all 32 teams will
participate in a practice draft to test
out the technology which makes sense
right yes it makes absolute sense
rehearse it practice it
it'll be funny to see what names they
come up with i i would like to be the
one who gets to come up with the
creative names of the fake players who
are drafted i think that would be the
most fun assignment of all because
obviously no one is actually going to
utter any real names of players they may
be interested in during this mock draft
but they need to be sure that everything
works because you've got a lot of moving
parts here you've got
a conference call line that is always
open that's something mike garafollo
explained last night on nfl network that
that is always a fail safe all teams are
talking on this conference call this
open line at the same time you've got
the various digital technologies you've
got different companies nfl partners
involved in this process to make sure
everything works and they're going to
test it out they should test it out this
is the way that they're going to present
the draft like anything else if you know
if
you just you test it out and make sure
it's going to work and this is a new
frontier this is a new unprecedented
mechanism for the league i hope they're
going to test the damn thing out chris
well
it's too big and too important for them
to just go into it and go all right
let's see how the whole system works i
hope it all goes goes well when it's
time for show time and the lights go on
no i mean of course not you know so
guess this is great that the nfl is kind
of giving it a trial run work out the
kinks you know see if everything
technology wise works the right way are
you going to be able to you know
pass off notes and certain phone calls
in real time and everything like that so
i think it's very smart by the nfl it's
good to hear that they're doing this now
and uh not waiting to the night before
or anything like that are you getting
crackling in your ears by any chance
because i am i'm i'm i'm not getting
crackling in my ears all right hold on
i'm gonna
i'm gonna reset my uh uh ipod so go
ahead listen i'm listening we we
apparently we apparently haven't tested
out our mechanisms before today's show
fortunately we're not going to be
involved in the draft of the
presentation of it
another issue that came up yesterday and
i think this is an important thing to
really understand completely thomas de
mitroff of the falcons is hoping that
there'll be some flexibility if teams
have technical issues now the response
to that is too bad everybody's on the
same footing everybody's got the same
rules no allowances for technical
difficulties plenty of ways to
communicate during the draft that was
the message that was communicated by nfl
network last night but i heard from
somebody who's with one of the teams
that said that there will be flexibility
they've been told they'll be flexibility
if there is a true technical glitch that
keeps them from doing what they need to
do there are multiple companies that are
involved in making sure that this
process is going to work out and they
don't want a competitive disadvantage
for somebody who truly has a technical
issue that keeps them from making their
pick on time because the low-tech
mechanism of running the card up to the
podium is not an option this time around
so
look
it's not going to be
a way for teams to say just give me a
minute just give me a minute
but if there is a serious technical
problem if there is a breakdown in the
communication ability of a team to the
league whatever it may be whatever may
come up who knows maybe there's a
lightning storm in one of the various
states in one of the localities where
people are trying to make these picks
there will be allowances there there
will be flexibility there the nfl does
not want a competitive disadvantage to
come from this process but they also
don't want
this to be a team's taking away from it
yes right well because because if
there's if the doors open far enough you
will have teams that try to take more
time the door is cracked and it's got to
be a legitimate technical problem
anything other than that too bad you got
to get your pick in on time
yeah well i i don't think we could go on
just like the honor i you know i don't
think you can go on the honor system
you're right i mean what if a team is
you know trying to wheel and deal a pic
and talking to guys and everything like
that then they realize oh man the
clock's ticking down here hey we got
technical issues and they buy themselves
three or four minutes i know but but
that there's no honor system necessary
when everything's digital and they want
to know if somebody's if you know i know
if you're if your camera drops i mean if
it drops if the communication is shut
down the energy you don't know i got
this crackling in my ear right now i
know that you don't know that because i
got tons of crackling no i mean
i'm sure it's not bentley chewing on
another bone
i don't think so i don't think that's
what he's doing but i mean either way
i i mean
oh okay yeah you're right the nfl is
gonna know i guess to a degree but if
you're the nfl mike do you put somebody
in all 32 buildings or have some one
person in charge of all of each team
within the nfl to know you know to kind
of give a little bit of a baseline like
oh hey there is this issue and then he
can get on the phone with nfl
technicians do you do something like
that how does that work to the checks
and balances of it all my understanding
is that and apparently they're going to
use verizon for a lot of the technical
communications and the the internet or i
don't know whatever it is verizon which
is an nfl partner is a big part of this
my understanding is that there will be
technicians on site at certain homes
whether it's general managers coaches
owners maybe three per team i don't know
but they're going to ha i mean this is a
big deal this is a major tv production
that they are trying to do with all
these people at home and it's not just
the tv production it's the actual
process of getting the draft executed
it's two things in one so they're going
to be deploying assets to make sure this
thing works out the way that it needs to
so even though it can't be used as a
crutch it is a reality it is on the
radar screen the possibility of an
actual telecommunications internet
whatever breakdown they're not going to
say to a team too bad you've missed your
pick we're going to move on to the next
team although the chances of everything
breaking down simultaneously from phone
to internet to all other communications
devices that is going to be a slim
possibility another issue that
apparently emerged over the weekend
kevin colbert the steelers general
manager who not long ago was saying hey
back in 1974 the steelers found five
hall of famers in the draft and we
didn't have pro day workouts and private
workouts and player visits to teams and
all the stuff we have today so we'll
just go back to 1974. well he wants to
go back to 1974 in another way he wants
more rounds for the draft i mean there
were 12 i believe back in the 70s there
have been more rounds than that in past
years now it's seven seven total rounds
for the draft kevin colbert according to
manish met of the new york daily news
suggested recently that they should add
three rounds to make up for the
inefficiencies and the incomplete
information that is available to teams
now this overlooks the fact that once
the draft ends you go get whoever you
want it's open season it's yeah
free agents you go sign guys why should
they have to the right to squat on three
more guys per team that's another
hundred guys who end up having their
ability to pick their first nfl
franchise
taken away from them all because we want
to give some sort of a consideration to
the fact that it's even more of a
crapshoot now than it otherwise is
that's not going anywhere that's not
going to happen and there are some
people who think this is a good idea i
don't the draft has seven rounds after
that you go out and you get whoever you
want whoever you can convince to sign
with your team and you know maybe the
thinking is some of these teams don't
want to spend more by way of signing
bonuses for the undrafted players
because it's going to be maybe more
challenging this year to identify who
you want and spend the money on the
right guys too bad go get your guys in
undrafted free agency the same way you
do every year that's going to be the
nfl's bottom line here and i think
that's the right way to do it well yeah
it's not even it's not fair to those
guys as much as there's a great honor
right to be drafted in general it's
it is not an honor to be drafted you
have been brainwashed and you continue
to be brainwashed it is an honor and a
privilege to be able to pick where
you're going to work once you have put
in multiple years of playing football
for free and taking all of those risks
for free when the time comes to pick
your employer you get to stay close to
home if you want to you would have liked
to have played for the new york giants
you didn't get a chance to do it because
somebody else drafted you first it's not
an honor to be drafted chris set that
bag down once and for all
no i'm not it was an honor regardless
yes i mean did i want to play for the
new york giants certainly but i was
still honored that somebody wanted me in
the first hundred pics of the draft and
thought me thought of me as talented
enough to help their football team and
my dream come true of playing in the nfl
anyway they can think that's the thing
you are the asset don't you realize that
you are the thing that has value you are
the person that helps them win football
games they have come up with a way in in
the spirit of competitive balance like
it really makes the bad teams better the
bad teams just draft the wrong guys but
in this this notion of smoothing
everything out and giving everyone a
fair chance they do this very
un-american process of letting people
call dibs on employees even though
there's 32 independent companies look i
didn't expect to get on this soapbox
today but quit saying it's an honor to
be drafted because there's kids out
there who are listening to you and
they're going to continue to think oh
it's an honor to be drafted it's not an
honor to be told where you're going to
work who you're going to work for who
you're going to work with especially at
the quarterback position when working
for andy reid versus working for
insert name of quarterback coach who
doesn't know what the hell he's doing is
going to determine whether or not you're
going to have a successful career
well yeah okay but that's the current
system and it still doesn't change
anything as far as you know i understand
what you're saying i i get it no but i i
can't
well would you keep me up because i've
done it
i don't get it you're right that you
don't understand it's the way this is
well yeah because i don't care
you're you're you're like in this you
know soapbox of like mike florio
unrealisticness and this is the way it's
it's the way it is in all sports mike
it's the way it's set up in this country
chris do you want to sit on the bench
behind patrick mahomes if you're a
quarterback who's coming out of college
football are you going to say hey i want
to play for the chiefs i want to win a
super bowl and i'll watch patrick
mahomes do it are you gonna go to a team
that has a need at the quarterback
position it's not gonna happen that way
and you can use a salary cap and you can
use a rookie salary pool and you can
give the bad teams more money to spend
on rookies so they have a better shot at
attracting those players but ultimately
it should be the decision of the player
this is the united states of america
life liberty the pursuit of happiness i
abhor the idea that companies can come
together these are 32 different
companies this is taco bell mcdonald's
arby's burger king wendy's taking a
total workforce and saying i've got that
guy i've got that person i'm taking that
person it's bullcrap and people need to
wake up to it okay ran over all right
either way better i got a lot of things
i want to complain about i just i i
disagree with you i don't know how i'll
have to formulate my you want to
better you chose to go to texas
i chose to go to tech and i tr you know
and i could say i i chose wrong in some
areas
why does it go but why doesn't college
football do that why doesn't college
football have a draft right why because
you get too much you go to college
okay sure so what what what's your
what's your point it doesn't matter
they're not doing anything like that
it's it's an honor it's an honor to be
drafted by the college that you attended
that's a great system and it's the best
sport we have in our country and the
best sport in the world and it is equal
in a lot of ways right we've seen a lot
of equality other than the new england
patriots dominating and it is very fair
the way it's set up and it's proven to
work and it's been working for a long
time it's plenty fair kids it is too it
is you you work hard you're getting
rewarded and you're getting paid to play
football and it's a dream come true so
what you're playing
you can listen to a ton of ilo wants to
play for the cowboys he's one of the few
guys who's been willing to admit you
know before the draft they're all
robotic oh i don't know i'll go i'll
play for whoever wants to pay me two is
willing to say i want to play for the
cowboys he should be allowed to play for
the cowboys if he wants to play for the
cowboys he's going to be sitting on the
bench watching dak prescott if that's
what he chooses to do he should be
allowed to do it that's my point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports